[Music]
hey everybody so I'm gonna use Ryan
fishes fish sticks for this tutorial and
I'm gonna show you a technique that's
one from Jay Firecat he's probably one
of the best one of my favorite he's one
of my favorite boo gang motivators out
there and the one I'm going to show you
today is really cool little sequence
that I learned at boo gang convergence
crystal toes that event it's really
really amazing happens in me I think
they just set the dates for next year
but I don't know if I'm gonna go but
we'll see all right so here's how we do
it we start we're gonna start with the
boo gang and I hand to tip position oh
let me show you this trick looks like
this okay so that's the trick and how
you gonna learn it is you're gonna make
this upside down mustache thing you know
a little mustache and you're gonna put
it over your neck and they're gonna
select one hand to pass it to the other
hand and here's a big trick here as I
get a little closer is that when it
passes your palm stays up to grab it
okay so fast motion
palm up okay and then I'm gonna for the
next step take it move it around and
pass it up at the top to the other hand
and then I'm around okay
to those steps again we're chillin we
began we put it over so I've kind of
passed it in the first case you can
throw it right so it's a pass or a throw
then I'm gonna spin it around my head
and then when they get to here here's
the cool part the boo gang that is in
front in my case that will depend on
which one you see but it's the one
that's hooked on my neck that one I'm
gonna let go so again
yeah I'm here and I just let it go and
boom I'm out pretty cool so one more
time I look for which one sucked on my
neck it's that one boom
all right it's pretty cool trick let me
see if I do it the other way uh-huh
there you go again I learned this from
Jay Firecat Abu gang convergence pretty
amazing technique and I think it really
starts the validity of contact with gang
it's a real it's really amazing and
really want to thank Ryan fish for the
fish sticks pretty awesome you can buy
them
I think lather from the spinsters and
yeah take care
[Music]